hey welcome back to Westeros weekly came
back it's happening again I'm Phillip
Melina and with me this week Erik Bosse
yeah guys with Game of Thrones season 8
upon us we are kicking off this season
of our Westeros weekly after shows with
to preview episodes over the next two
weeks before the season premiere hits us
on April 14th yeah it's been almost can
you believe this has been almost two
years since season seven I was what 15
this is crazy I was important yet yeah
we know that you guys probably don't
remember that much I'll be super honest
even though we're super fans like we
still have to remind ourselves of how
much happened in just in last season
alone yeah it's all hazy up there you
know you may have vague memories of
things like greyscale or grey worm the
movie the gray the wolf movies having a
side story all right so we're here to
cut through all of that fog and get all
of your lingering questions answered
that's the purpose of this shows
answering your guys's questions of
course we're still gonna do our
breakdowns Erik's gonna do a great job
on that I'm excited for those but and
that's what we'll do the deep dives and
get into all the imagery and all the
things you missed here it's all about
you guys and what you're wondering about
and whatever it is that every week
hopefully the whole world is probably
freaking out about will react to that
first here if you're watching this on
YouTube also remember you can now listen
to it as a podcast we're really excited
about that you can actually download the
show in audio form a little earlier than
when the video comes out but even more
exciting than that this will be like a
little bit earlier at the breakdowns
that you guys are always hounding Erik
about in the kindest wave like when's it
come out I knees in tears about it
that's gonna come out earlier on the
podcast too yes like a decent amount
earlier it's so much faster to do the
audio then the video of those breakdowns
so if you guys are like I need it as
soon as possible to impress my friends
at work or whatever the podcast is works
at so you're gonna want to subscribe to
that on iTunes or anywhere you listen to
your podcast look up specifically the
feed is called Westeros weekly but it
will have this show it'll have the
breakdowns and it'll have any kind of
special Game of Thrones related video or
audio that we do during the see
yes you can hear us on your commute or
and then once you need that visual
component you can watch that later and
then you have both senses you ever hear
a robot learn how to be human you just
did I have not learned yet yeah for your
commute your visual senses can be
simulated as well in cortex I leave
three of the five all right so let's get
started as we always do on this show
with the biggest question that we have
right now and this is kind of developed
since last season it's a little bit of a
theory that people are wondering about
so our big question do we have it just
come in to us oh we got the big question
coming who threw a question at us let me
see this yeah that was through podcast
listeners a bird just flew into the
studio and delivers the big question are
you ready bye bird yeah flying back full
of cameras oh he's gone alright podcast
listeners loving it
so the big question who betrays John
which is very interesting right it's not
something that people hadn't been
considering but at well I think this is
pokemon battle girl maybe is who kind of
started bring this to our attention a
lot of you guys have asked us about yeah
yeah well a quick reminder of how season
7 ended it ended with that confirmation
that Jon Snow is not only the son of
Lyanna stark and rhaegar targaryen which
we already knew but that he's not a
bastard at all it was a legitimate son
they got married and that makes him the
rightful heir to the Iron Throne more
rightful than really any other character
unless you consider the whole conquest
of the Iron Throne by right the surfer
technically like didn't have the right
so the Targaryen according to them would
have more of a right to it but sure sure
now that news was actually brought to us
by ace investigative reporter Gilly
Pei is she she found that a note of
Rhaegar Targaryen but you know you don't
have to pronounce things right to get it
right as we just learned how to read
hours ago it's a big steps big steps
she's taken now only brand and Samwell
Tarly actually know the full story
they had that conversation at the end of
season seven and one of them is going to
deliver this news to Jon Snow yes one
will deliver
very insensitive ly and just like just
like matter-of-fact and the other one
will just stutter his way through it
until he cries and John holds him but to
get to this question of who's gonna
betray John we know John already has
some obvious enemies right Cersei
Lannister
you're on Greyjoy they already outright
hate this guy when they had that big
powwow at King's Landing and they've
already teased that they're not going to
be playing on this side that they're
pretending to play on in this upcoming
season yeah they're there outright gonna
they were out for blood but the reveal
of his parentage might make some other
enemies up north there's a couple people
who might want to stab him in the back
others wounds yeah scar collection that
he already has his body his ripped toned
scar riddled body just like me now I
think it's important to note here that
we don't mean like these are people who
have secrets secretly always been
against John I think that is is almost
the easy way out
it's realizing that him being revealed
as a Targaryen changes the playing field
for them and it actually means does John
have ulterior motives so these could be
justified people at least to some extent
so remember that you know John was a
very decent dude and he was kind to the
free folk and that got him stabbed to
death just because of the difference of
perspective right on like who your
allegiances are my point is snow knows
betrayal by the way snow knows potential
name for a direwolf if there's another
one that's gonna show up I'm gonna write
a ton of screenplays hello in my head he
was like potentially Air Bud equivalent
but you're like yeah yeah but like a
coke addict disqualified for the season
here's we were talking about this how
things just seemed looking a little too
neat a little too tidy at the end of
last season if the good guys on one side
you have the night king and the army of
the Dead on the other side and then you
have Cersei and you're on Greyjoy you're
just kind of waiting to take on whoever
survives that battle between good versus
evil man versus nature but there's no
way it's gonna be that simple right
george RR martin loves to subvert
expectations pull out the rug from under
us
anytime we start rooting for one
character for one side we end up feeling
really bad about ourselves my are the
worst people because they seem to always
come out on top now so we're going back
to this idea of there's shades of grey
and there are other characters who seem
to be on Team Jon and Daenerys who are
probably going to flip on them betray
them or let them down or disappoint them
in some way well or even just
disappointed and let down Jon right for
sure like so first up is his partner in
and all the boat rocking we saw last
season and his aunty Daenerys right I
actually don't think that she would mind
being related to John remember it is a
different time it was the 80s but
there's there's even the chance that
like maybe she makes that like him more
remember that that is a Targaryen kind
of tradition they try to keep their
bloodline very pure I they purposely did
it a lot of times they would Wed brother
to sister so she might have no problem
with that but she might have an issue
with him potentially having a claim to
the Iron Throne we know she's been
pretty intense about her being the only
rightful heir so as the only surviving
son of the firstborn son of the Mad King
he technically does have a stronger
claim we went over to that first second
ago but she spent what one - seven
seasons thinking that she should be the
rightful ruler of Westeros and
practicing meanwhile he's like got good
at dying yeah yeah yeah absolutely
Daenerys his whole claim is that
Robert's rebellion was illegitimate he
stole the throne that was not a legit
that broke the Targaryen Targaryen
dynasty and that forced her into
seclusion exile but now that she's still
alive and she has an army that gives her
stronger claim but now that John yeah
it's a grandson he has a definitely
stronger claim and her whole idea is
that she wanted to break the wheel right
she wanted to smash the page right how'd
you say it I'm going to break the wheel
yeah I'm just gonna like pimp a rock out
and make him do impressions I could
that's a deep cut now so here's the
question is she gonna conquer all that
land with her dragons just to give up
the crown to a very handsome nephew that
she's hooking up with she's a mad king's
daughter she has a temper we saw her
burn randyll Tarly and his son diccon
Tarly and that was very recent that is
not at night oh yes it is like she had a
chance to show mercy to them and win
over some of the Lords of the crown
lands or the friendly to Highgarden
people yeah and she said no you guys
were [ __ ] I'm gonna burn you alive
in front of all of your men so this is
the daughter of the Mad King that we're
seeing right now and like not to not to
get to science here whatever but mental
illness is many times genetic yeah it's
interesting some people are saying that
with the Targaryen has proven it's not
like you know how Cleopatra's brother
through incest I know I know they don't
have physical deformities but it does
lead to some kind of like a couple
screws loose brain deformity yeah yeah
okay so I think there is a decent
argument there honestly I think that
would be great conflict to for the
upcoming season is introduced these two
lovers and then immediately have them at
odds with what who you know should be in
charge
I don't know that Jon would stand up to
that right like he might be like
whatever right you do you girl yeah but
it would be really interesting could you
imagine if Romeo and Juliet actually
climaxes and like the fact that they
have to now fight for the Montagues and
Capulets and like against each other
like you know while being in love with
each other's a whole better epilogue
here come on like learn something right
I wouldn't and your story yeah so that's
one potential solid option but also
there's another semi blood-related
option if someone I think that could
potentially cause him some drama and I
think we saw hints of that
that's a Sansa oh yes yeah she's gone
against John before right especially
when Littlefinger was influencing her he
was really trying to set her up to
potentially he thought chaos was a
ladder he very much thought that she
could be the one that's left over at the
top of that so if you remember the
Battle of the bastards
she called in the Knights of the Vale
without telling John it was weird
she's no power move save the day at the
same time so of course she's legitimize
would have been nice to know that maybe
three think is strategy
lose fewer northerners yeah you ever do
something like that is like technically
bad but then it works out so you don't
apologize yeah it's justified the means
there yeah I'm referencing something
specific you did to me and we'll talk
about it later but so John was running
around at that time he's wandering
around Westeros you know being like
Johnny Appleseed of whites just I don't
really know what I mean by that but uh
but he was a planning and apple of a
white and in every different place you
know I I didn't grow up speaking English
Johnny Appleseed kidnap an apple tree to
prove to other people that apple trees
existed I thought he was the founder of
Apple computers in the 70s in a garage
with a big ashton kutcher me yeah yeah
all right yada-yada John is a climbing a
beanstalk heard of her around Westeros
but Santa's stayed in the north and what
does the north do they never forget
especially when it comes to Targaryen
who they fought a war against not that
long ago in this culture you passed your
grudges along to your children our
culture too so northerners are already
gonna be very pissed that their king
bent the knee to a Targaryen that's not
something that's really gone around yet
so when they find out that he is a
Targaryen that Umbridge of the umbers
that's gonna come oh yeah a conniption
of the Karstarks that alliteration those
blows over k right
Sansa takes her ruler duties very
seriously and managing her alliances
maybe she takes that as seriously as
being a stark which technically by the
way like she's gonna feel like she's
really the Stark here not him could
Sansa siding with the northern houses be
something she does against John and
maybe be that bittersweet ending that
George Norton keeps alluding to and
maybe testing by us to see if that's
clearly what he's doing is wondering
what we're gonna like could that be it
though she would get to complete her
journey she that's basically been her
arc right becomes some end
pendant actualize leader at the expense
of potentially what's gonna turn out to
just be her half-brother slash cousin oh
yeah remember that she also started keep
going here but remember that if there's
a character that she's most like now its
Catelyn Stark who is the one person who
was able to have almost like an
allegiance to technically raising John
and you know making sure that he's fed
and cared for but no love for him right
yeah I didn't want to see him succeed if
there's any character that she's more
like it would be Cersei like there was
some evidence at the end of season seven
that she was picking up some political
tactics from the stylist she tricked a
little finger into coming into what was
essentially a false trial not unlike the
green trial that blew up the Sept of
Baelor which you know there was a fake
trial that end up just being a trap the
same way that was for Littlefinger so
she's in many ways just as treacherous
potentially as this woman who was
basically her captor for years so yeah
it'll be interesting to see if that
happens but there's another character
surfer in stone himself Jorah Mormont I
sorry can you pronounce his name again
very clearly Jorah Mormont I meant sir
friendzone he he has betrayed Daenerys
before right he he promised queeth from
Qarth way back in season two that he
would never do it again but that doesn't
mean he won't betray someone else
especially a guy he's jealous of the
person who he feels could be a threat to
his queen Jon has been a bunch of things
Jorah was never able to be Daenerys his
lover he's like a son to draw his father
G or more Mahmut Mormont he actually got
the sword that Jeor Mormont was supposed
to give to Jorah but because Jorah sold
slaves he was exiled from from Westeros
he's got like a sweet like sword holding
spot in his cave or whatever yeah there
was that moment where like where Jorah
refused to take back long cloth he does
have does get that but at the same time
he didn't really know like oh but also
you're gonna take my girl but also he's
got that greyscale and sure it seemed
like Sam cured it but who knows what's
going on and weariness and they say
greyscale if there's anything it's
similar to you'll understand this
syphilis so this idea that it doesn't
just have this grotesque way that it
affects you but also it drives you mad
thank you for syphilis splaining to me
yeah that would imply that I have
syphilis
uh-huh but maybe we all do
is that the thing that you're mad about
apologize like it turned out okay so I
didn't get mad so I think Jorah is
honestly just like an easy easy guess
honestly like he might even try to
betray him and not even be the biggest
betrayal yeah you know who I think would
emotionally be the biggest betrayal for
John hmm Arya yeah you know yeah that's
a good point so they were very close as
kids even though she clearly has changed
a lot if anything she's grown far more
than he has he might be you know the
king in the north but Arya is like a nun
she's unknowable to the person that she
was before the stranger yeah exactly
so you know now she slits throats and
wears people's faces on the Reg I think
that she'll still be cool with him when
they reunite initially she talked about
being a fan of dragon riding and the
warrior Kings are Visenya and rain rain
nice I don't rain is yeah the other
sister yeah rhymes with anyway and so I
think she will be jazzed to potentially
have Daenerys in her family they can
talk about killing Lords another fun
like girl stuff
but that said he's like maybe if if it
matters to her more to to like a lot
it's tough now that I'm saying this I'm
wondering like about to say if she needs
to side with Sansa for some reason maybe
she would turn on Jon but as soon as was
about to say that I was like maybe we
should be wondering is already gonna
turn on Sansa yeah I don't know if Arya
is that interested in northern politics
you know and whether John was right to
bend the knee to this Targaryen
interloper to me arias journey has been
more defined by her kill list in her
desire to get revenge so that's an
interesting point how about the fact
that does she care more about succeeding
completing her kill list than she does
about defeating the White Walkers yeah
protecting Jon and it's really none of
she it may be a foreign betrayal I could
see her leaving the battlefield
altogether and being like you know what
this isn't my fight to fight I need to
go down south there's people who are
still walking and breathing who need to
die right now let me let me give you an
image it's gonna it's gonna be
ridiculous but it at least
undertale explain like conceptually what
could happen she's in battle she's like
being a badass just like swinging around
people's necks slicing their heads off
and she sees in one part John is
fighting you know who knows the night
king or something they're having like a
badass battle and she like is like oh
maybe I should go help him and then out
of the corner of her eye she sees Cersei
trying to you know find her a contact
lens on the ground and she's like oh but
I could knock out my kill list right
here and someone I hate so much and be
torn between helping her her brother and
someone who she loves and fulfilling
everything that she's been training for
and like her mantra right she almost
brainwashed herself yeah what do you
think is more likely I think it's more
likely that she goes back to her mantra
I mean I imagine I what I hope happens
is some kind of like cyclical repetition
where the way to hound left the fight at
Blackwater and he saw fire he goes and
he left I kind of want Arya to repeat
that move her trigger would be of ice
versus fire or maybe someone dies and
the Battle of Winterfell ends very
poorly for the heroes and they are left
scrambling and they all are scattered I
mean her direction that she ends up is
south right the batter of Winterfell is
episode 3 I think we've heard this
season that's you know the midpoint
right like if we're gonna end
structurally on a win hopefully fingers
crossed
then the midpoint probably are gonna be
at their lowest low yeah it needs to be
um yeah it needs to be a mess at the end
of that battle at the very least but
let's talk about everyone's favorite
eunuch Varys right yeah that guy's he's
always got something up his sleeve we
don't know what his whole game plan is
but he claims to serve the realm and
that he believes Daenerys is good for
the realm and so long as Daenerys stands
by John you have to imagine that Varys
would - but he's got a very confused
outlook he was told by Melisandre that
he would die on Westeros and that kind
of that screwed up his mind a little bit
so you have to wonder what he's working
on I kind of feel like when Littlefinger
died that kind of changed the rules of
the game on the show - we're like
cunning technicians and political
masterminds like Littlefinger and Varys
have lesser of a role to play and yeah
it's almost the the famous scene from
Indiana Jones right with the guy was the
amazing sort play or whatever then India
shoots him yes we had a dysentery that
day and oh boy
but I I do think that you have a point
that you know the people that we see die
on the show are the people that don't
adapt and change and Littlefinger we're
gonna talk actually about him next
episode I think about what his real deal
is but this episode it's worth noting
that if he is dead mm that it might be
because he stuck to his version of
playing the game while the game was
evolving and he didn't evolve with it
yeah
now Varys is probably the person I
played the game most similarly and very
much always has these secret games that
he's he's up to his whiz in a box right
we heard we talked about earlier I think
that one thing to note though is that if
there's a single singular motivation
it's the good of the realm and I think
it's not hard to think of what side he's
gonna be on unless Danny dies and if
Danny dies everything I mean this guy's
so planned at planning ahead you know
he's got like all right who's number two
who's number three he's got his order of
succession
it's a Secretary of Education on there
somewhere I'm wondering who he
immediately aligns with if Danny I mean
Tyrion would probably be his go-to at
that point maybe just interesting cuz
this Tyrion want to lead yeah I feel
like those are a lot of good options I
want to take some people just off the
plate of just I don't think it's gonna
happen and it's just honestly just
they're they're too honorable mm-hmm
Brian and Davos yeah I think both of
those people just like don't understand
what it means
yeah like loyal to a fault probably
maybe yeah I saw his great thing I've
just like nobody says anything and
Brienne's like I swear allegiance to you
like she's just so ready yeah so I think
they're too good for this I think that
the noblest most honorable characters on
the show I
they'll probably poison everybody and
run off together because I said that you
know hey this picture could be their
wedding invite yeah podcast listeners
its Brienne and Davos just making out
fiercely be lucky that you're listening
to this yeah
all right cool so now before I get to
the strongest candidate to betray John I
want to ask you who you think I'm
thinking of
mmm let's see strongest candidate to
betray John the mmm I can't read your
mind okay I was just testing that and
I'm glad to finally find out it's true
all right
Tyrion didn't oh yeah for sure oh yeah
obviously
today I didn't know if you had a more
obscure Ian sir yeah well just Tyrion
like has kind of become a little bit of
a slightly watered down more mellow
version of himself over the years he
very much has like like John in the past
but he's no stranger to lies and
betrayal and here's my big thing that I
think is like secretly happening in the
background
he's probably in love with Dani oh you
think so
yeah I mean get in line like who is it
yeah but but also like you know Charles
been on deck for a while like all these
people have reasons why they could
betray John remembering the dragon pit
in the season 7 finale when John angers
Cersei by saying that he's already bent
the knee to Danny
Tyrion tells him have you ever
considered learning how to lie every now
and then oh yeah I feel like maybe
foreshadowing potentially of like
there's something that he's not being
honest all right and then after that
there was that scene where he had a
meeting with Cersei and then it was
after she revealed that she's like a
tiny bit pregnant but then we cut away
from the rest of their conversation they
didn't show us how that conversation
ended right and I remember at the time
Lisa when we saw that we were like you
know it's kind of weird how right after
that Cersei came back to Jon and
Daenerys to announce sure I'll send my
troops to help fight the dead that's
weird that that would be Circe's
negotiating position right like you
don't put your foot down and tell your
brother you're pregnant and then back
away from where you put your foot down
earlier that's odd
Cersei didn't get to be queen baby bad
negotiating or not having some kind of a
secret plan which is about to blow
everyone up at a Sept I think I think
Tyrion must have offered something to
Cersei secretly on behalf of the stark
Targaryen alliance like some people are
thinking maybe he promised Cersei that
Daenerys would name Circe's baby as
Daenerys his heir and I know that sounds
crazy until you remember that everyone
thinks Daenerys cannot have children
right now anyways right so maybe he told
his sister about Daenerys his loss drag
and Viserion and told her to lie about
sending her troops north
and cersei doesn't need to learn how to
lie from Tyrion she's already great at
but Tyrion might have definitely like Co
lied with her it just definitely feels
like if Tyrion is still in this story
it's not just to align with somebody
else right he's just too interesting a
character he is that you know we were
talking earlier about that thing you did
to me but it ends up being for the
greater good right mystery I think that
absolutely that's the kind of thing that
Tyrion would do he's almost a more
active aggressive version of what
they're not sorry of what Varys does
like look it's for the greater good
even if it means ultimately betrayal he
also has no issue with being accepted as
a villain and somebody who's you know no
pun intended but looked down upon
right like he's like fine I'll play that
role I'll be the bad guy if it means
that we win at the end of the day his
rage at the people of King's Landing
during his trial it's a good moment to
be a scapegoat and if you kind of think
like you guys are like nah that's not my
Tyrion I'm gonna remind you where we
left
Tyrion last season when all right Dan
and Johnny are on The Love Boat
so he he made this face and I love it
thumbnail we made about this where say
why he mad why he mad
yeah and it's because uh you know
there's a lot of reasons actually I
guess why he's scowling it's not just
that they're there knockin boots in
there and he's not getting to play along
it's maybe he feels betrayed by both of
them like that I mean like to put that
in front of what they what they actually
have going on
he certainly clearly seems like he has
the weight of the world on him in that
moment yeah I mean maybe he's just mad
that their love will cloud their
judgment as they lose sight of what the
real problem is but maybe it's also true
that Tyrion wants to save both you know
the Westeros but also the Lannister
family and maybe this lie if it's
possible between him and Cersei well
keep the northern forces focused on the
dead if they defeat them the northerners
will be weakened and it'll make them
more likely to have to seek a truce with
the Lannisters now South Bend the need
of them potentially to do that he would
have to sell out John and Danny probably
compromise everyone's chances at
surviving sure and not having all the
armies of Westeros to fight the night
kings or having to fight a war on two
fronts really hurts
chances of John and Danny and makes
Tyrians betrayal he all the more bitter
if we think that's where his characters
gonna go man I kind of all that said
it's like wow we made a decent argument
there maybe he will he will do that and
then I'm like oh dang I hate when your
favorite character on the show might
just piss you off
real bad even if it's really great good
what do you guys think
I mean look surprise us in some way yeah
let's know in the comments if you're on
the Himalaya listening to us on podcast
there's also comments on there that we
can check out but yeah I don't know I do
here's the one thing I think it's not
gonna go well for John right if there's
just a little too much Allegiance going
on we already know that Cersei is
planning something but I think the the
fact that we know that kind of like
lessens the surprise then so that means
something else is gonna surprise all of
us Jon included yeah well that's the
story on who's potentially gonna betray
Jon coming up later on in the show we
are going to take your Twitter questions
and do our best on answering those but
that's not the only way you can
participate on it because remember last
season but we did Power Rankings where
you guys actually helped us figure out
who's kind of winning Westeros that week
and there's a lot of different ways
right like even though Arya isn't most
likely to end up on the throne
necessarily in one week she certainly
ended up at the top of the Power
Rankings on that first episode you know
when she took out a whole family basic
right yeah on her own so what you can do
you can tweet those questions at us with
the hashtag Westeros weekly but on that
same Twitter account at new rock stars
you'll be able to follow we're gonna
post how you can help contribute to
these Power Rankings each week then we
use this really intense super mathematic
machine Devin's calculator and we'll
produce our our weekly Power Rankings
and then announce those every week but
again you guys totally help us figure
that out so as a recap for where we left
the Power Rankings last season it ended
with John Cersei and euron greyjoy
the Russell Crowe of Westeros in a
three-way tie for third place okay
actually Danny was in second place and
if you're wondering well then that's all
the big characters who's in first place
boom the night king oh yeah
for sure right because he certainly won
that season yeah he knocked down the
wall he got a dragon yeah he didn't lose
at all
he's a great spirit thrower yeah yeah I
mean you worship him in every way I
thought we weren't gonna get into my
religious beliefs on this channel I said
that's all we're gonna get into but
anyway so that was like two years ago
though I mean Eric went there puberty in
that time a lots changed
yeah reborn yeah so I think that if
there's a chance that maybe with some
trailers and some distance maybe some
power rankings have changed maybe
somebody full finally throw samwell
tarly the respect he deserves
I mean he cured greyscale he figured out
John isn't a bastard he's gonna figure
out probably how to start making
Valyrian steel again which is a long
lost art he's the hero of people who
believe that just through research and
reading enough Wikipedia articles you
can really change the world yeah if he
were alive now he'd have a dope YouTube
channel oh all right just throw my
Manson boats okay so we're gonna like
update that in future weeks just make
sure to follow our Twitter account all
right so let's move on with what we were
saying I forgot that we were doing this
Raven thing Raven has has flown in with
a question oh it's a note for me do you
like you can make someone else's wax
seal yeah send the raven back the raven
brings us a question from at heaven drag
Neal okay yeah this is a question that
we've all been asking right which
characters do you believe will actually
survive all of season eight mm okay
funny of this person mentions that
because here's something new we're doing
this season of Westeros weekly death
pool death pool I'm Deadpool so it is
part of uh cinematic universe and Liam
Neeson is part of it yeah yeah okay
great
that was my one Deadpool impression this
merger allows everything to be a CIT
owns all Mickey Mickey he's going to
take the throne he already sits on the
throne too much okay this is getting
weird so let me get back to this death
pool so what you guys need to do is go
to
guess the throne calm and on their
search for Westeros weekly we have our
own poll that we're also gonna link to
it on Twitter and you guys can pick who
you think is going to die during the
final season of the show and then we'll
see if your predictions are actually
better or worse than miner Eric's if
they're better than Eric's you can have
his job so and then we'll shout out also
the the folks that do the best on the
show we're kind of like say hey look
who's currently doing the best on our
pool and then the grand winner will get
a prize Eric it's something better than
my job yeah my home eleven dollars
alright that's better I'll take the
eleven dollars yeah any form of payment
I'm sure you'd appreciate all right so
in our next episode we're gonna go over
who we think will live or die and why I
haven't finished all of my research on
what I'm how I'm deciding that but I do
think that it's a different bird I'm so
embarrassing to you yeah they look like
Eric we just got another raven in i love
the people that are playing this in
their car right now and swerving every
time they hear all right so just a
burning question here who's the bigger
threat so upcoming the season the night
king or Cersei oh it's just think
calling it a burning question right
because fire it's important for the
first episode we've known about this
creepy looming threat from the from the
north right and that's the White Walkers
but there's also another threat Cersei
Lannister and her often poisonous wine
now sure the night king can turn a baby
into a blue-eyed killer with just a
touch but Cersei can turn a man into a
baby with just some truly killer
side-eye
and she doesn't need to touch you if she
does you'll probably die as the sand
snakes found just yet the kiss you can
kill someone she had that big moment at
the end of season six obviously where
she grew up the great set cept I like
you called it the the green trials that
the name that people are calling it yeah
cool alright nope
and basically she knocked out all of our
haters and one fell swoop so then in C
the seventy was kind of a bit quieter
right she was like laying low she's just
like chilling as like the dark black
goth Queen which actually was like
therefore for sure but then the night
King kind of took all the attention that
season that said doesn't that feel like
rhythmically that my swing the other way
yeah she seemed to what were her big
moves right she she got revenge against
the sand snakes for Marcella she wanted
gold from Highgarden and then she has
this pregnancy negotiation and in this
possibly secret betrayal against the
forces of the north but I don't think
we're done with her right like there's
gonna be more politics more maneuvering
and you know there are no dragons and
giants a magic reanimated corpses but
the most important moment of the show
according to George or Martin really the
politics the the depths of human nature
how evil can people be in their pursuit
of power and no one has been the poster
child of that more than Cersei on the
show right and the Lannisters in general
right the the people who executed Ned
Stark the people orchestrated the red
wedding right so if we're if there's one
last-ditch kind of like playing the
politics it's got to come through Cersei
absolute are we saying that Cersei is
actually the bigger threat you know it
depends on on
she's the threat that could cost them
the war with the knight King for sure oh
absolutely she could be the spoiler that
and I think there was the theory that we
brought it before that the knight King
might fly this area on south to King's
Landing first there was a brilliant
person already who came up with this
idea that he might go to the to the
south to King's Landing turn convert the
army of the golden company and whatever
forces Atlantis ters have and then
Knight Queen Cersei joining with him
could they could join forces and become
an equally deadly threat north I love
when I can't figure out our way out well
they should lose yeah of course also if
season eight is about to be this giant
fantasy world version of a zombie movie
which oh my god that's how awesome this
season's gonna be I just realized what
is the top lesson that we have learned
from zombies and in previous movies and
in TV shows it's always about the other
living human you have to worry about the
most right obviously The Walking Dead oh
my god they are the walking dead right
they are the monsters right again
there's more
right at this point I mean it's kind of
just like you know avoid the side of the
road and don't go in a forest or
whatever
Carl has been the most deadly character
or the walkie dead right yeah basically
to merciful stop letting in outsiders
Cersei is the Carll of Westeros yeah
seriously I don't get what that means
right everyone scream producer says same
haircut oh that's what this always wears
that cowboy hat that's how they cut it
it's a bull coat with the cowboy shirt
all right but she's got some weapons
heading into season eight she's got your
own Greyjoy he's still fine he's still
trying to bet himself with a queen
Cersei is a good option for him you
almost didn't say with a queen chick
he's still trying to bed himself trying
to learn but the she's also has a
fiercest Navy of Westeros with the iron
fleet he has the silence the battering
ram ship that's been unbeaten he's and
currently he's shepherding the 20,000
member army of the golden company from
Essos and we saw a piece of that in the
trailer right there was we saw that's
not all of them right yeah now that
looks like 20,000 on one ship is just
round up yeah if you guys are listening
to podcast it's a picture of Varys and
Brienne making out so it just explains
so much in these things but tell you
about the golden company here for a
second one I just think it's funny that
if it's really what's really following
you know the history of the world as its
played out which he tries to sample from
very likely if they get caught in a
hurricane hopefully gets sunk and like
these people are just all on the bottom
of the ocean yeah but say that doesn't
happen
it probably won't the golden company
just a reminder for you guys of why
they're a big threat they are the sell
swords from Essos they're kind of like
the second sons that daughter and the
harris was the leader of but honestly
these guys have a better win-loss record
yes different mercenary army yeah and
and now we often establish on the show
that mercenary armies aren't necessarily
they have no allegiance right but that
said this is a very very threatening one
this is also moving on this is the one
that's backed by the bank yes the iron
bank gave Cersei right to be able to pay
for exactly and so I you know the iron
bank definitely operates off of
statistics and so they feel like this is
statistically the
biggest impact they can have on the wall
the Westeros equivalent of betting
markets right bud right yeah yeah Betty
markets work anyway so they famously
don't break their contracts so we
shouldn't have to worry about allegiance
the golden company says that their word
is good as golden company so that's a
fitting pairing actually for the
Lannisters who always pay their debts
like well you they're not gonna break
their allegiance and the Lannisters
aren't gonna forget you know what what
they owe their other motto for the
golden company is beneath the gold the
bitter steel together yeah that's much
better one right yeah that's supposed to
like buy our mattresses yeah and your
gold necklaces mattresses yeah
bittersteel go with bitters you guys
better still an important word here so
well okay so that's a reference to their
bow one obviously it's it's a reference
to sword right the taste of sword in
your mouth I'm not feeling too good but
also it's actually more specifically a
reference to a Gore rivers oh yeah yeah
they called him yeah bittersteel they
even carry around this is amazing his
gilded skull meaning they literally
carry with them a golden version of
bittersteel skull like a dipped it in
gold held it I guess by like a stick and
you know and then you dip it into gold
you remember yeah yeah I was part of an
improv cult that did that alright so
they're led now by this guy Harry
Strickland of the boy band of Fame
anyone solo alright so we think he's
kind of like this Jamie look-alike if
you look at this picture in the season 8
trailer I think it's very interesting
that just as Jamie has left sir see a
new Jamie is gonna like show up and look
exactly like the way he used to be in
the version that she loved instead
they're like kind of weakling that she's
come to know recently in the books Harry
Strickland is chubby and gray-haired and
complains about how much his feet hurt a
lot so it looks like they're going in a
slightly sexier direction there's
probably a reason for that right alright
people don't like to look at how it goes
on
these screens and fog but there might be
a plot reason a narrative reason in
order to create some tension between him
and your honor
yeah what's funny is that you remember
again you're on is trying to bet himself
Queen and so for him to bring over like
this like like pretty boy is probably
not the smartest move yeah you know it's
interesting that they're bringing in
this new key player in this final season
of Game of Thrones as big as important
as the golden kept the company is in the
books it's like we have six more
episodes why are we seeing them this
late for the first time in season eight
now that could be mean that they're
playing a bigger role in and Circe's
endgame and it could be more evidence
sort of that theory we're talking about
that they're just there to be a larger
army that the knight King can convert
into white water right right would you
do that yeah which which does a nice job
also of my favorite thing in in later
stages of a conflict is actually going
back to what we already have and then
you know making that worse all adding
the golden company is a little bit
adding a new player but going back to
what we have and you know converting
them great they're just making people
that's much more interesting to me
hopefully it goes that way also just to
mark the golden company were formed by
the exiled
bastards of King Aegon the fourth yeah
what started the Blackfyre rebellion
right so you had a bunch of bastards
kind of like Robert Baratheon or Erik
Bosse but on his deathbed he legitimized
all of those bastards actually and then
he proceeded to fight several wars
against a god are there children in the
Blackfyre but those are to take over the
Iron Throne so this is not only like a
feared elite military unit we have here
but they're also one whose leaders are
all descended from dark Aryans who all
say they all thought they should be the
kings ascend Seven Kingdoms so I'm
thinking that instinct is probably
kicked back in for them maybe if they do
show up this is if they're like gonna be
a better threat than just being part of
the rankings army yeah oh yeah Cersei
has a golden company on her side but
let's remember she also got her own
zombie oh yes a mountain and her old mad
scientist
Qyburn yeah dark I burn yeah we got to
go back so is he sitting on a cache of
wildfires yeah that's interesting does
he have his
own army of zombies that he's been
working on this whole time he kind of
semi perfected it with the Undertaker
version of the mountain you know maybe
he has filled under King's Landing a
bunch of those also you know they've
been working on this remember a way to
wound a dragon yeah over his scorpion
the giant crossbow they called the
scorpion pretty effective yeah uh what's
his yeah he used that to take down in a
train battle right and it worked
yeah it's one of the few times where you
know just making a typical weapon a lot
bigger made it more effective doesn't
work with guns so much but yeah so
that's a thing that is still in play
right now I think it'd be against the
Targaryens yeah this is the first time
that we've seen Cersei without anything
to lose remember at the end of season
seven Jaime told her I'm the only one
you have left our fathers gone our
children are gone it's just you and me
now but then he left and then without
her cooler headed brother by her side
she could be even more unhinged this is
the woman who's blowing up half of
King's Landing and she said afterwards
that it felt good to watch them burn you
know she has become a Mad King or mad
Queen in her own way and her only
objective is to survive and stay in
power for herself and for her quote
unborn child if it even exists yeah now
we don't we still know what the night
King once but his trajectory is pretty
clear he wants to march his army south
and probably try to kill everyone in
this way with Cersei it's hard to tell
right she's holding her cards close to
the chest she's a powerful wild card
with some wild card friends it makes her
a bigger threat in a lot of ways to the
endgame in the series
I think we talked to golden company
death I think we should probably get to
another question
it's polite not to ask okay all right so
let's do this note says okay well we
have a bird indoors which is not a good
idea
alright so speaking of Qyburn at maple
chiefs is asking is there more wildfire
was it depleted was it all used a bailer
and the Blackwater yeah I think that's
an interesting question I think there's
a very good chance of wildfire will play
a part in season 8 you know there's a
question we asked after Blackwater did
they
all of it no Searcy was still making
more of it and it was they brought up
several points that it was stored
underneath important places in Kingsland
and including the great Sept of Baelor
and I think it would be foolish of
Searcy to have used it all just to blow
up that one major building you would
think it would be an important weapon to
have not only against your enemies
politically but an enemy that is
particularly vulnerable to fire ie the
whites now we don't know if the night's
king and the other white walkers can be
killed with fire it's supposed to just
damage Yammy you can't club but he can
put it out he can put it out when he was
chasing Brandon to hold the door episode
he was able to create like a you know
like Moses kind of great gap between it
but it is an effective way to burn a
bunch of stuff fast including an army of
whites if need be yeah I don't think it
was all used up that big all but Sept 6
yeah they probably would made a big deal
about it if they were like this is the
only time we're ever gonna be able to
use this I'm sure you know that Searcy
and KY burner made probably getting more
wildfire priority and especially
interesting now that they can use it to
kill White's
John's display of burning the captured
whites hand in front of Cersei and
Chiron obviously would have taught them
like hey by the by if you happen to have
secret fires - maybe let's use that yeah
there's also just this lingering threat
of Circe's nuclear option of burning
down King's Landing the whole city like
she mentioned a willingness to burn it
all to the crown on more than one
occasion and when someone repeats a
threat like that you got to start taking
him seriously a fire in fury there's
never a good way to go and recall that
Jamie got the nickname Kingslayer when
he killed the Mad King before he could
burn down King's Landing so Jamie and
Cersei seemed set on a collision course
I would say in season eight with their
encounter could mirror his encounter
with the Mad King could he have to
repeat history could the Kingslayer
become the queen Slayer would that
fulfill the whole von Kahr theory that
she was told in the books that she would
die at the hand of the younger brother
with her twin brother being born couple
minutes after her yeah it just depends
on if he's a bigger fan of Queen or
Slayer right
well I totally missed uh we got another
question I completely missed its mark
but Eric got it great cool that looks
like a broken wing by the way you can
mean to mend that all right okay this is
a very important question from @omg
Productions pod rootsMagic rod are we
gonna find out why it works so well why
he mad we've gotten a lot of variations
on this question actually yes
yeah besides Jamie's hand this is
probably the most mentioned body part in
the history of Game of Thrones I'm gonna
go out on a limb mm how big of a limb
are we talking what area I want to know
I'm giving them what they want Phil
syphillis remember okay no it's probably
a pretty big lamb as we're saying and I
don't think we're gonna see is uh you
know golden hand we made it this far
with no pod fro full-frontal that said
it's the last season I'm gonna guess the
series is gonna conclude with the image
just in our imagination we're not gonna
find out why it's like the mysterious
city of a sigh yes right very similar
but like a penis yeah we know from the
season 8 trailer that we're gonna see
pod in action it looks like that action
is probably gonna stick in battlefield
and not in bedroom though
I mean you could get down on the
battlefield I think if there's one kind
of dirty joke that will be finally
revealed it's gonna be Tyrians honeycomb
in a jackass joke it's not gonna be pods
right rod how that plays I'm sure it'll
pay off hopefully well there's so much
more to talk about next week including
some things like the crypts of
Winterfell what's going on with bran and
a major character that died in scene 7
that might still be alive if you have
enough tin foil to wrap around your head
yeah all right so uh next week also is
gonna be the final pre premier episode
these preview episode so we're doing
that you say that five times privation
save five times fast fast all right it's
gonna be our preview episode of Westeros
weekly so if you have any other
lingering questions specifically ahead
of season a make sure to tweet
with the hashtag Westeros weekly in the
past we also asked for users to send an
artwork based on whatever stupid silly
bits we had during the show keep doing
those parent salute simplest from your
art never tell an artist to limit them
so we don't want any creative
interpretations for what it is let's
stick to the textbooks yeah all right we
would love people also is something new
we're doing we don't have a lot of music
options here we can't use any anyone
elses music so if you guys want to
submit like a jingle or theme song we
can use as maybe like the outro of the
podcasts or of our show we totally will
maybe use it yeah channel your inner
Ramin Djawadi he's the composer of Game
of Thrones and send us something that
will set the mood for your show I think
feel free to have lyrics in there too or
just dogs barking over the Game of
Thrones theme if you try to watch a show
with dogs sometimes they'll Park during
it whatever you're feeling you know we
won't say no to anything you guys thanks
so much for watching I know that's a
genuine thank you you guys are great
don't forget to subscribe both to this
channel for ongoing Game of Thrones
content the breakdowns that are gonna be
coming just as soon as we can after
every episode but again if you want them
a little bit earlier or you want to hear
this in audio form Westeros weekly the
podcast stream you can find that
wherever you get your podcast follow us
on Twitter at new rockstars that's where
we're gonna be posting all that stuff
about where you can participate in the
poll that's we're gonna send your
questions with the hashtag Westeros
weekly you can follow me on Twitter by
the way at fimo let me follow me a ta
vos guys I'm freaking hype oh yeah
you're excited if I Ain't air Hortense
right like let's work on getting those
Ravens less dangerous in future episodes
guys more dangerous more danger
[Music]